I lost this just notify the insurance
company immediately let's hope that
doesn't happen though
bunch of big guys out there with guns to
make sure he doesn't get lost
[Music]
what's up GQ I'm Nick Cannon this is my
Patty elite I've always had a love for
watches all the way back to the old
school swatches back in the day but this
one obviously is quite different and a
little bit more expensive my autumn arse
on my pad is probably among my favorite
ones enough for some reason I just
started to collect them and spend too
much money on them my son want more
watches they can definitely have my
watches hopefully I can pass down some
things that would allow them to earn
their own watches I hope they take that
from me more as an idea of just my my
tangible material items my canon class
notebook I am currently a student at
Howard University hu you know class of
2020 going down I'm old fashioned
like when I'm at school and I'm taking
notes there's nothing like just jotting
down quick ideas and things to remember
I will have a master's in criminology
hopefully before 2020 and then hopefully
from there and get my doctorate I'll be
dr. Canyon before you know it my laptop
truly the essentially it's the wave
attack case from vintage cases this has
a MacBook in here my first Mac laptop
was stolen it was my friend
it fell off the back of a truck somehow
we got the whole laptop like a hundred
and fifty dollars and we didn't really
do anything on the laptop but we were
just really cool to have this you know
Macintosh laptop this is like millions
and millions of dollars of ideas all in
here so all my homework is connected to
it as well like Howard University
haha no so much stuff music poetry
scripts my life if I were to lose one
thing that would devastate me it would
be this computer right there this is the
brain it can't in essentials black card
the limit on the black card is there is
no limit so you could buy whatever you
could imagine I always wanted one but my
accountant always told me that I didn't
need one for so many years I finally got
one I got two it's like retail therapy
right you feel bad about spending the
amount of money that you do but at least
the person that you know charging you
acknowledges that you have some black
cards like I should feel a little bit
better about yourself but it actually
really doesn't mean that much it's more
to me for the vanity of it all but to be
a vain guy true essentials things I
really can't live without my medication
I'm probably the the perfect conundrum
of someone who will preach about
holistic values all time but would be
the first person to call my doctor when
I first was diagnosed with lupus in 2012
I had to take 30 pills a day now I'm
down to each to definitely a true
believer in mind over matter and mind
body and spirit all intertwine and it
starts with the mind the body is a
self-healing organism if we give it
everything that it needs to heal itself
we have it we're made from carbon and if
we continue to put carbon in and create
the electricity that taps into the
spirituality that taps into the mind
portal
turbine up is a freshman I cannot live
without my turbines for so many reasons
there's actually become like a fashion
staple for me which I never thought it
would be and I didn't even wear I'm in
public that much I would do it in like
my cultural studies and less spirit like
in yoga and like it started when I was
doing that and in high school I tried it
and it didn't stick like he was like
take your grandma's catwalk so then one
of my confidence and what drip got all
the way over like I'm gonna do that
again
it's been about 15 years nobody gonna
tell me what to do now and it all came
together it was the universe for the
Topton to what I was studying at the
time and it allowed me to be able to
share these different concepts with
people one wore a turban is to be
sovereign sovereignty just means to be
self-governing or just to know that your
own oneness within governs and helps you
make those decisions and therefore the
people who wore turbans were wise and in
tuned in the line in a way that others
weren't so they were safe havens and and
I thought it was fly like I had a turban
to match every outfit right wherever I
go and the cool thing about it i
incredible headphones every time I
travel always have these not just
because they're mine that these are
probably the best headphones on market
for the amount of money headphones have
definitely become a fashion accessory
and their statement you know they speak
to a specific demographic you know it's
usually gonna be a music lover someone
who's on the go and they become like
part of my swag I got this people moan
all the time she's like the turbinates
and headphones that's all you'll see me
on Louie Vuitton travel bag I do not go
anywhere without this bag carrying my
toiletries in here obviously everything
that you've seen so far from my laptop
to my headphones it's just this is like
my murse the reason I love this one so
much it's cuz it
has this like camping bag cause this
thing one that's on my back passed away
at least 85 and if Louie Vuitton drip is
crazy alkaline water a lot of people
feel like they don't believe in ionized
alkaline water but I definitely can't
tell the difference I believe water is
like the Fountain of Youth I believe
it's the secret elixir to keeping me
healthy so I drink about two gallons of
water a day can't live without water
none of us can live without water but I
really try to get as much water as
possible Lancer this stuff is like super
serum people always say like I have nice
skin and this is probably one of the
reasons why but it's always been hard to
maintain because and I don't know if I'm
always being on airplanes occiput my
skin tends to get really really dry
myself and my dermatologist dr. Lancer
came up with you know some formulas to
keep me moist I'm so reckless with it
like I'm just saying I'm one of those
dudes like that everybody's like you're
rubbing your face too hard like now I
gotta get in there gotta get the pores
Nick Cannon
thanks for watching this has been my
essentialist
[Music]